I have always wanted to like fly somewhere for the day,
like fly and come home in the day.
And I did that yesterday.
I had this like event that I had to go to in Los Angeles.
I had to do my own makeup.
And I promise you these makeup brushes that I got from the TikTok shop.
It's like a 48 piece kit. It comes with like all these brushes.
And the reason why I love it is cause if I fuck up,
I'm just like, fuck it.
And then I get another brush.
I don't have to worry about like figuring it out
cause I always know what the fuck I'm doing.
But it comes with these brushes,
it comes with these like little cleaning cloths.
It comes with this thing to clean your brushes,
a bunch of makeup sponges,
a bunch of these little things.
Like I feel like a fucking professional,
you know? The makeup application is to be decided,
but the tools are top notch
and they're linked right here.